it doesn't do a lot of interviews so I
feel very privileged to be sitting down
with DJ mugs what's happening Brother
welcome man thanks for having me man
hell yeah soul assassin's three Death
Valley is out yeah man and what a track
listing wow man some [__] on
there some [__] on there for
real yeah some of my favorite new
rappers man like you know Bodie James
shout out to bodies you got Ghostface on
there yeah oh yeah then we got some of
the classics and [__] yeah ghost and gun
shout out to TF man I was gonna say like
it's crazy because I remember
The Source uh uh advertisements for the
very first Soul assassins album which
was what 97 or 98.7 Yeah man so like
Fast Forward uh I don't even want to
talk about how many years that is
because it'll age you and me a lot but
for you like what's what is changed
about putting together a soul assassin's
album after you know 25 years later or
whatever it is
um and what kind of still fuels you to
be so passionate about this [__] because
you were active still to this day you
you know you're always dropping projects
joint projects working with
up-and-coming artists man yeah um part
one was um
back then it was pre-mixtapes before
mixtapes got really crazy so doing a
record like this was something unique
you know what I mean there was only a
few [__] doing that where I
just a lot of people was asking me to do
tracks for them for their albums and I
was like man I'm good man I just rather
just build my group and do my [__] but
I'm you all can come and be on my [__]
then once the mixtape Eric kicked off
everything was just mixtapes so then it
was just
it was was nothing's really special
about making these records no more
because you can go get a fly ass mixtape
yeah so I was like I don't think I'm
gonna do another one
so I just I record all the time so
recording the homies come through record
record stacking songs stacking songs and
I was like I got some [__] right here
what am I gonna do
and I was like I've had three or four
different ideas the way to put it out
and then um I was just gonna probably
drop a song every two months for the
next three years and then gold watch
came through and I was like yo I need
you to help me figure something out man
I need to build something visually for
this record because I don't feel like
just doing um videos yeah the video I
saw that I only saw the trailer but the
trailer looked like a [__]
full-fledged cinematic experience 100
and I was like I'm tired of videos man
what can we do bro cause I'm not putting
this record on I was like let's let's
build something that's like 10 15
minutes long he's like man that's a
that's that's gonna be hard and I was
like you know [__]
and um we started we should we shot and
um pre-prep for like a month we ended up
shooting in Death Valley
um Oakland San Francisco
Vegas LA and ended up being a 34 Minute
movie
crazy yeah we shot videos we shot music
videos and they're in the movie on the
TV like in a trap house mayhem's videos
on the TV in the trap house
Rock Moss he's building a bomb
that's crazy and um you know his video
I'm watching his video
in in my house while he's building a
bomb in the video I'm holding the bomb
so it's psychedelic it's like I don't
know if you're familiar with
alejandroski so I'll compare more like a
jadorovski meets Pink Floyd with hip-hop
yeah it's crazy because I feel like not
like you said back in the day what you
did was unique and I feel like in
today's climate doing a 34 Minute like
mini movie is unique as well we've seen
like movies to go along with albums I
feel like people don't do that [__] no
more because they're like so worried
about like the microwavable attention
span of people instead of like yo let me
do something dope unique creative yeah I
did it for me man I can give a [__] you
know what I mean I did it all for me
like how can I keep myself entertained
yeah now can I do something just fun
just to get up and do everything some a
little challenging some I ain't done
before so that was the driving force
behind it for me yeah I didn't did
everything I've set out to do years ago
so you know just keep them just keep
tricking my brain and stretching myself
and having a good time doing this [__]
is that what keeps you going it's like
I'm doing this for me really like I'm
gonna do it for me but you know at the
same time man I love I love the kind of
music we make this underground hip-hop
[__] that it's nothing different than
I've always made but you know I figured
I can come here now and just Champion
what's going on and just build build
this culture and make it bigger and
stretch it make it stronger you know
what I mean sure Inspire the youth and
then also give guidance and and and let
them tap into my fan base you know what
I mean and grab some of these youngsters
and like show them show them the way
yeah it's been dope to see like your run
it just continue and I I just had this
talk with Al recently because I'm always
trying to push rappers to do albums with
Alchemists that you know I just did this
with Jadakiss on the podcast I was like
why haven't you done a whole album with
Alchemist no [__] all right crazy that'd
be crazy but like to see you like you
know you're like like always working
with artists and like doing like
full-fledged like bodies of work whether
it's like Jay worthy or Mayhem Lauren
like you're very much like you know it
feels like you're still in your Peak and
you're still like
like you said the the underground [__]
has changed over the years the
quote-unquote underground hip-hop [__]
has definitely changed from what like it
might have been in like 2000 2001 or
whatever but like you're still like
fully engaged and like pushing that
culture and like to me that's that's
very dope because you know just from a
DJ perspective like I find the little
things that keep me still like motivated
and engaged to try to like still listen
to new artists you know what I mean and
and um so it's just dope to see you
still you know fully [__] in it bro
yeah man I'm you know just having a good
time man and you know just to be able to
just hang out and kick it with the
homies and um talk some [__] you know
what I mean what was the uh the homage
to Death Valley why so so assassin's
three Death Valley on this because
that's the title of the movie okay
that's the movie that's the 34 Minute
movie that comes with it it's Death
Valley you know it's the hottest [__]
place on Earth it is you know what I'm
saying so and it's you know and one of
the things in the movies I left LA to
get away from the heat
um you know go to Death Valley yeah it's
ironic right it's very ironic sure what
was uh for you because you know there's
always so many
when you have so many moving Parts on a
body of work when it comes to getting
artists to like uh sign off on stuff you
have to deal with that kind of stuff
yeah every you know a lot of everybody
on this record I've have relationships
with them in the past you know so it was
pretty easy man it was pretty this this
record was pretty easy there was nothing
nothing crazy
yeah and also like a lot of guys are
independent right and they run in the
game a little bit different these days
like you know before dealing with majors
and dealing with labels and the
sign-offs and yeah the clearances and
the sample clearances she was a headache
you know a lot of times right now you
can be under the radar with a lot of
this [__] and a couple well I always
static selector always told me
because I was always like hey bro like
you guys clear clearly samples and he's
like man he's like look bro
he's like we just let [__] fly and if we
got to get it clear later that means
it's doing something basically if it's
under a certain number they ain't even
coming they didn't waste any time you
know right it's like and if it pops off
later then you know it's all good well
you know what sucks dude is like I don't
know if you've if you've experienced
this from your perspective but a lot of
like major label
artists or the labels will be very
specific to make sure like I play me
some window sample oh you don't even
want to clear samples anymore they don't
want to deal with this [__] because they
get hit hard man like like a major is
going to have to deal with that [__] you
know what I mean and they're going to
get hit because it's a major and they
know they got bread so
Universal is reaching out as opposed to
like it freezes up the whole project you
know thank God now they just got to pull
a song or two off a Digital streaming
site instead of pulling all the records
off the [__] shelves that [__] was a
lot easier yeah imagine having to go to
Every record 500 000 records out of
Tower Records and you know all that [__]
did that happen before you've seen it
happen with Biz you've seen it happen
with um
um truth hurts with Dre with the rock
himself that was a big Bollywood sample
yeah
that's a lot of [__] money to eat
you're pulling a [__] million pieces
of vinyl off the shelves